>> Jill Garcia: Hello everybody.
Welcome to the national
book festival.
Are you guys excited?
Come on. I am here to
introduce Chris Grabenstein,
who is a number one New York
Times bestselling author
from the action-filled Escape
from Mr. Lemoncello's Library.
He has several more
books in the series,
which I'm sure you all are
aware, and he also has Welcome
to the Wonderland Series, and
he's cowritten numerous books
with James Patterson like
I Funny and Jacky Ha-Ha.
Well see, there we go.
And Treasure Hunter series.
Chris Grabenstein has received
many awards including the Agatha
Award for Best Children's and
Young Adult Novels four times,
and from what I can tell,
he also has a wickedly
fun sense of humor.
His newest book is
Welcome to Wonderland,
Sandapalooza Shake-Up,
and he also has a really
big surprise for you guys.
You're going to want to
stick around for this.
He's going to be signing
at 1:00 over in line 14.
Please welcome, Chris
Grabenstein.
>> Chris Grabenstein: Thank you.
>> Jill Garcia: You're welcome.
>> Chris Grabenstein:
Thank you so much.
Thank you guys for coming out.
It's great to be here
in our nation's capital.
They put my slide up on
the, I need my slides now.
Okay. Do we have any fifth
graders here in the audience?
Any fifth graders.
Up on that screen
right now is my picture
when I was in the fifth grade.
Have any of you been able
to figure out which one
of those kids I was when
I was in the fifth grade?
Anybody want to guess
who thinks they know?
Yes, which one was I?
>> On the top row.
>> Chris Grabenstein: Top row.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
On this side.
Oh, the guy with the blond hair?
No, his hair is blond.
What color is my hair?
[ Inaudible Comments ]
What color did my
hair used to be.
Black. It used to be black,
so you're looking for someone
with black hair up there.
Yes, which one was I?
[ Inaudible Comment ]
The second row in the
little turtle neck.
He's got a receding hairline,
looks like he's going bald?
No, it's not me.
I didn't start going bald
until like ten years ago.
That kid was going bald
in the fifth grade.
By the time we got
to sixth grade,
we all called him Chrome Dome.
Now since I mostly
write mysteries,
I'm going to give you
guys a clue right now.
When I was in fifth grade,
my eyesight was better
than it is today.
I did not wear glasses when
I was in the fifth grade.
Who seems to know?
Yes, which one was I?
[ Inaudible Comment ]
The one in the red T-shirt?
Oh the one T-shirt,
no his hair is blond.
Have any of you read
any of my books?
Has anybody here
read one of my books.
I'm giving you another
clue right now.
Have you read my books?
Yes, the young man
in the red shirt.
Which one do you think I am?
The one in the red shirt.
Yes. That was me
in the fifth grade.
Let's give this guy
a round of applause.
So I show you that picture
for a couple reasons.
One, to prove before my
hair started going gray,
thank you very much
for notice that.
Before it started going
backwards on my head,
I was actually at one point
in my life 10 years old
and in the fifth grade,
and in the fifth grade is
when I first started
having fun writing.
I used to do these
little comic books
where I'd draw the pictures
and make up the stories
and pass them out to my friends.
And when I was in fifth grade,
I grew up in a little town
called Signal Mountain,
Tennessee, which is outside
of Chattanooga, Tennessee,
and the local Lions Club had
an essay writing contest.
I entered and won first prize.
That was my first
writing award ever.
It was a cream puff
day in our house.
Then I went to Junior
High School,
and I got the bowl
haircut going guys.
I recommend that look.
It's a good look.
You just put a bowl
on your head.
The chicks dig it.
And I worked on the
school newspaper,
and I had a really
good English teacher.
And her name was Mrs. Garrett.
Are there any teachers
here today?
Teachers, you have the power.
Let's give a round of
applause for teachers.
They don't get enough
love in this country.
Let's hear it for teachers
because Mrs. Garrett,
my own goal, whenever we
did a homework assignment,
I wanted to make Mrs. Garrett
laugh, because I wanted to write
like Art Buchwald or
Dave Berry or somebody,
just to make her laugh.
And she liked my essay so much
that she wrote in the margins
of one of my papers, you
will make your living
as a writer someday.
And when a teacher tells you
something, you know it has
to be true, because teachers
everywhere, take a solemn vow
to never ever lie to children.
Isn't that right teachers,
you all remember
that day in college.
You had to raise
your right hand.
Plus, you know, my parents,
if they said, oh Chris,
you're so talented, you could
be a writer, I would have said,
you're my mother and
father, you get paid
to say nice things about me.
But when a teacher tells
you something, you go,
ooh, maybe that's true.
Maybe I've got a little talent.
So by eighth grade I had
made up my mind that I wanted
to be a writer when I grew
up, and I can prove it,
because my mother saved my
eighth grade composition book,
and every year when
I was in school,
we had to write the same essay.
What do you want to
be when you grow up?
And I used to say I wanted
to be a doctor or a lawyer
or a chemical engineer like my
father, but in eighth grade,
inspired by my seventh grade
teacher, this is what I wrote.
But now my mind wanders to a
new thought, to be a comedian
or a writer is my quest.
If this flops, I would be
content to be a millionaire
and run Grabenstein's
department stores
if I could ever fit
the name on a sign.
Got a B plus on that.
I'm looking for a
retroactive A minus at least.
I got a B plus on that.
So now, I am living
my eighth grade dream.
These are all the
books I've written
so far for guys your age.
I start out writing a bunch
of ghost stories called
the haunted mystery series.
And then I wrote the
island of Dr. Libris.
Some of you have read
the island of Dr. Libris,
that's one of my favorite.
And then this guy named
James Patterson called up.
He needed a little
help and said,
could you help me
write a couple books.
And I said, yeah, sure
Jim, what the heck.
He was actually, James Patterson
and I go way back to 1984.
He was my first boss
in advertising
at the Jay Walter Thompson
Advertising Agency.
So before we wrote about
treasure hunters or funny kids
or houses filled with robots,
we wrote about flame broiled
whoppers for Burger King.
Good times, good times.
So we've got I think
22 books tog,
and some of you have read Escape
from Mr. Lemoncello's
Library, is that right?
Ooh, thank you.
Any of you from Virginia,
because it won a book
award in Virginia.
So, thank you all,
you Virginians.
Thank you very much.
And that book was turned
into a movie on Nickelodeon.
A little bit of advice,
never write your book
report based on the movie.
They're always a
little bit different.
Read the book please.
And that was kind of fun
because it starred this kid,
Casey Simpson, who stars in that
Nickelodeon show Ricky Dickey
Donkey Dorky Dooky--
[ Inaudible Comment ]
That's it, I can never
remember the name of the show.
And also Brianna Edie was
in the show, and I got to go
out to Hollywood and got to
be on the set with everybody.
And it was a lot of fun.
There were great actors.
And then I got to go
to the movie premiere
and walk the orange carpet
because it was Nickelodeon,
everything is orange.
So that was great and,
but now I'm going to share
with you guys before,
we're going to go
to questions right away
because I know there's a lot
of questions.
I'm going to share with you
guys some coming attractions
for next year.
First off, James Patterson
and I have a new book called Max
Einstein, the genius experiment,
all about a girl
named Max Einstein.
I think it's the first book
endorsed by the Einstein estate,
so it's kind of exciting.
And then, for you Lemoncello
fans, in October there's going
to be a three-book box
set that comes out,
and inside that box set there
will be a bunch of bonus puzzles
and stuff that you can play,
because we're always
getting asked,
can I have some more
rebus puzzles,
so there will be some
bonus puzzles in there.
And then, the fourth
book in the Welcome
to Wonderland series
comes out in April,
and it's called beach
battle blowout.
And then James Patterson
and I have another book next
April called Cat Versus Dog,
which was a lot of fun.
But now, for the first
time ever, I can announce
that there will be a
fourth Lemoncello book.
[applause] No one in the world
has seen this cover until today.
Until today.
This is big.
So this is Mr. Lemoncello's
all star break out game.
[applause] And it will be
coming out in, I think in May.
I never know when these
things are coming out.
It's coming out in May, and how
many of you read the third book?
How many have read-- so that
was all about nonfiction.
The fourth book is all going to
be about the power of fiction.
That's why there are windows,
doors, and mirrors on the cover
because if you read a book, you
get to live someone else's life
and walk in their shoes
for a little while.
So Kyle and his friends
are going to be
in something called the
fictionasium in the fourth book.
So that should be a lot of fun.
So I didn't want to
yammer all day long.
I'm going to have some
questions from you guys,
because I know a lot
of you have questions.
They have two cool microphones
here, so why don't you line
up on the microphone so I
can hear your questions.
I'll get some water too.
Yay. Yes, sir?
Oh there you go.
I think I just heard it come on.
>> What was your inspiration
for Mr. Lemoncello's Library.
>> Chris Grabenstein:
Mr. Lemoncello's Library
was inspired by the fact
that when I was a kid
librarians were all
about protecting the
books from the children.
You'd go into a library,
and they go, shhh be quiet.
You'll wake up the books.
Or get your sticky
fingers off the books.
And then I started
doing school visits
when my haunted mysteries
came out,
and I met all these really
kind of fun librarians,
and the library became the
center of activity in schools,
and I said, where
were these librarians
when I was growing up.
And then I went on a
school visit to a school
in Brooklyn called PS10.
It's in Brooklyn, New York.
It was made out of red brick.
It's three stories tall,
been there since
1932, forget about it.
So I say, it looked
like ordinary school,
but then I went upstairs, and
they had a brand new library.
And I asked the librarian how
did you guys get this brand new
library in your otherwise kind
of old-fashioned building,
and she said, oh,
a very generous millionaire
donated it to us.
So that day on the
subway ride home I took
out my writer's notebook
and my pen and I wrote
down the two magic words
that have started every book
I've ever written, what if,
what if a very generous
and somewhat loony bazillionaire
donated a library to the town
where he grew up, and that's
how the whole thing got started.
Good question.
Thank you.
We'll go over here now, yes.
>> How much books do you have?
>> Chris Grabenstein: How
many books have I written?
Thanks to my friends at
the Library of Congress,
they just told me I have 62
books in the Library of Congress
because I started out
writing books for adults,
and I wrote like
nine or 12 mysteries
and thrillers before I
started writing books for kids.
So I have 62 books in
the Library of Congress.
I'm going to go over there
and look at them some day.
It's kind of exciting.
Yes?
>> Have you ever had, have
you ever had writer's block?
>> Chris Grabenstein: Have
I ever had writer's block?
No, and if I was doing
my school presentation,
I would show you how to
never have writer's block.
Do you ever have writer's block?
>> Yes.
>> Chris Grabenstein:
Here's the problem.
We all sit down and try to make
what we wrote perfect the first
time through.
Well, you know that book Escape
from Mr. Lemoncello's Library?
>> Yeah.
>> Chris Grabenstein: I worked
on that book for two years,
and I rewrote 50 percent
of the entire book
at least eight different times.
>> Wow.
>> Chris Grabenstein: So nobody
gets it right the first time,
and if you quit trying to
make it right the first time,
you will never ever ever ever
have writer's block again.
So remember, the first
draft is just for you.
Give yourself permission to
write a really bad, terrible,
stinky, no good first draft,
and you'll never have
writer's block again.
>> Okay.
>> Chris Grabenstein:
There you go, yeah?
>> What was the inspiration
for Charles Chiltington?
>> Chris Grabenstein:
Charles Chiltington.
Well, when you write
a book that you have
to have two characters at least.
One is the protagonist.
That's the hero.
You're going to follow
them through the story,
but they've got to butt
heads with an antagonist.
So I tried to make Charles
the opposite of Kyle,
where go you remember the
very first time you meet
Charles Chiltington?
Where was he?
Do you remember where he was?
>> In his study.
>> Chris Grabenstein: In
his library in his house.
So does he even need
a public library?
No. He has all the
money in the world,
so Kyle's attitude is knowledge
not shared remains unknown.
Charles Chiltington and his
family think knowledge is power.
I'm not going to
share it with anyone.
So when you write a book,
it's almost like you're
doing a wrestling match,
and you got to have a good guy
and a bad guy, and they're going
up against each other.
So that's where Charles
came from, and he was based
on every snobby person I've
ever met in New York City.
>> Thank you.
>> Chris Grabenstein: And
we have a lot of them.
Yes?
>> What was your inspiration
for The Great Library Race?
>> Chris Grabenstein:
The Great Library Race.
I wanted to, you know,
I was with a teacher.
I get a lot of my ideas
when I go on school visits,
and I was with a librarian
or a teacher who picked me
up at the airport or
whatever, and she said,
I wish you would do a
book that taught kids
that research means you
go back and you re-search.
You don't take the
first answer you find.
And when she told me that,
the little lightbulb
went off in my head.
What if in this game they
discovered some fake news
about Mr. Lemoncello, would they
believe the first they found,
or would they dig deeper
and find the truth?
So I wanted to do a fun
story about research and how
to do proper research.
Good question.
>> Chris Grabenstein: Oh, yes.
Over here.
>> What's it like to
be a successful author?
>> Chris Grabenstein: I'll let
you know when it happens, no.
[laughter] I never think
of myself that way.
I just have a lot of fun writing
stories and making stuff up,
and it's thrilling for me
to see this many people
have read my books.
So, yeah, the first time my
book became a New York Times
bestseller, we did
a little dance.
I think it was the happy dance.
So that's kind of exciting,
and it was fun to see a movie.
Because my mom, who is
92 years old, she said,
I remember when you were a
kid, I said one day I'm going
to see your name on that TV
screen, and I did last night.
So that kind of stuff is cool.
But thank you for
calling me successful.
Thank you.
Yep?
>> How long does it take
you to write a book?
>> Chris Grabenstein: Too long.
No. How long does it
take to write a book?
I write faster than most people,
which is why I do
eight books a year,
but each book probably takes
about six months to a year.
I can write the first draft
in four or five months,
but am I done when I
do the first draft?
No. I have to rewrite
it to make myself happy.
Then I show it to my wife.
And I rewrite it
to make her happy.
Then I show it to my editor,
and an editor is like a teacher,
and they'll read your paper,
and they'll send you a letter.
It's known as an
editorial letter,
and the last one I
got was 13 pages long,
and there's always one
paragraph that goes, oh,
Chris, you're such a genius.
This is going to be a
great book, great book.
And then there's 12 pages of,
but you might want
to think about.
Then it wraps up with
a, but you're a genius,
it's going to be a great book.
They call it the
compliment sandwich.
They put the compliments
on either end like bread,
and then they stuff
it with all the meat.
And so will go back and forth.
My wife and I just finished
writing a book together,
and we did six major rewrites
on it, and now it's all done.
So it's a fun process.
I'm lucky I've had really
good editors who only want
to make the book the best it
can be, so it's a fun process.
Yes?
>> I love writing, and I
wanted to know what was,
what was the age you were when
you first wrote your first book?
>> Chris Grabenstein:
My first book?
Well, I wrote, I've been writing
since I was ten years old
in the fifth grade, then
I moved to New York City,
and I did improvisational
comedy with a troupe.
We had a guy named Bruce
Willis in our troupe.
He shaved his head,
moved to California.
We don't know what
happened to him.
And I did that for
like five years,
and then James Patterson hired
me at J. Walter Thompson,
so I wrote commercials
for almost 20 years.
Then I started writing
movies and stuff.
My first book was published two
days before my 50th birthday.
So it's a really good sort of
second career or third career
for anybody who thinks
about being a writer,
because the average age of
every New York Times bestselling
author is 56 years old.
So I still had six years to go.
So I was 50 when the
first book came out,
but I didn't get
started till late.
You know, I didn't think I
could write a book until,
again if there's any aspiring
writers here in the adults,
read Steven King's
book on writing.
That's what inspired me
to think I could do it.
Yes, over here.
>> What's your favorite of the
Mr. Lemoncello's Library books?
>> Chris Grabenstein:
I love them all.
They are my children.
It's like asking me to
pick her favorite son,
and she had five
boys in seven years.
She'd pick me.
I guess I love them all.
Probably the first
one would still be my,
will have a special place always
because it was the first book
of mine that anybody
ever heard of.
I was at a book festival
in Atlanta, Georgia,
and I had 30 books published,
but Mr. Lemoncello came out,
and it was a New York
Times bestseller.
I think it's won 42
different state book awards,
and they introduced
me as, here he is,
debut author, Chris Grabenstein.
It was like the first
book anyone ever heard of,
so that will always have a
special place in my heart.
>> Thank you.
>> Chris Grabenstein: Yes?
>> When you wrote your
eight grade composition,
what you wanted to be
when you were older,
did you really expect like that
you would be an author now?
>> Chris Grabenstein: I
didn't think I'd be an author.
I knew I would probably be a
writer, because I wrote skits
for my friends to act in, and
I acted in a lot of plays,
which is another good thing, any
of you guys want to be writers,
see if you can work with the
drama club or act in plays,
because that's all about
dialogue and character,
but I thought I might
be a writer,
but I thought I would
work in journalism,
which is what I studied
in college or television
or advertising, because
I had to make a living.
It's very hard to make a living
as an author when you start out.
Yes?
>> When you won the essay
contest in fifth grade,
was it a cake day at your house?
>> Chris Grabenstein: Well,
you've read the second
Lemoncello book.
That's good for you, because
in the first Lemoncello book I
talked so much about balloons
that every school I visit,
they'd have balloons.
So, when I was a kid, if one
of us did something exciting
like got in an honor society
or won the science fair,
my mother would make
these cream puffs.
So we literally called
them cream puff days,
and I remembered that when I
was writing the second book,
and I said, I'm going to
establish cake days for Kyle.
That way when I go
visit a school,
there will always be
sheet cake waiting for me,
and there has been, and that's
why I've gained 20 pounds.
Okay. Yes?
>> How hard was it to
write a lot of books?
>> Chris Grabenstein:
How hard was it?
Well, at first it
was really hard.
Have you ever given
anything to your teacher
and they've given it
back to you and said,
you can do better than this.
Have you ever been rejected?
>> No.
>> Chris Grabenstein: Oh, well
I was rejected for four years.
I quit my job in advertising.
I was living off my savings,
and I wrote my first book.
It took a year.
We sent it out to every
publisher in the New York,
and guess what they all said?
No, we're not going
to publish this.
You have been rejected.
And then I wrote another
book, took another year,
and they all said, you
have been rejected again.
Then I worked for a third
book for a third year
and got rejected again.
But fortunately during this time
I had Chinese food for dinner,
and one night I cracked
open my fortune cookie,
and inside was a slip of
paper that said get knocked
down seven times,
stand up eight times.
So I took that fortune
cookie, and I taped it
on my computer, and
I kept going.
And my fourth book
that I wrote four years
after I started was the
first one that got published.
So, yeah, there's a lot of
rejection along the way,
but if you love doing
it, it's a lot of fun.
Yes, over here?
>> So in the Nickelodeon movie
for Mr. Lemoncello's Library--
>> Chris Grabenstein: Uh-huh.
>> We watched it in
class, and we all,
whenever we stopped it,
we all were like, no.
And then we, the next day
our teacher was like only
if you be good, then you can
watch it, and so we all tried
to our best, and we got it.
And one of my favorite
parts was the hover books,
and also loved the part
when, what's his name?
>> Chris Grabenstein:
Charles or Kyle?
>> Ky--
>> Chris Grabenstein:
Kyle's the main guy--
>> Who's the mean guy?
>> Chris Grabenstein:
Kyle and Akimi.
>> Akimi, I think.
He set off all the things.
>> Chris Grabenstein:
Yes, they set it all off.
>> So, yeah, and--
>> Chris Grabenstein:
It was a fun movie.
It was kind of nice to
be used as a reward.
I'm boosting education.
But you know what
I like even better?
I hear stories that sometimes
teachers will be reading the
book aloud and the bell will
ring and it's time for recess,
and the kids will go, we
don't want to go to recess.
Read us another chapter.
So that's good.
Well, I'm glad you
enjoyed the movie.
Thank you so much.
We'll go over here
because I just got
like five minutes left I see.
Yes?
>> Why did you decide to
do a silly book instead
of a normal book?
>> Chris Grabenstein: Why did
I decide, you've known me now
for 15 minutes, and you're--
I've been a silly
person my whole life.
When I was a kid, we
didn't have books in school.
Well, we kind of did,
but it was all things
like Red Badge of Courage.
We had something called SRA.
Anybody else old
enough to remember SRA,
the color-coded essay?
So we didn't get to read
books like you guys did,
so when I was a kid,
I read Mad Magazine.
I got my first subscription
to Mad Magazine
when I was ten years old,
and I would watch Rocky
and Bullwinkle cartoons,
and that made me a
permanently silly person
for the rest of my life.
So I don't think I can
write a serious book.
Yes?
>> So what gave you the idea
of making a book about robots?
>> Chris Grabenstein:
A book about--
whenever I write
with James Patterson,
he comes up with the
ideas, and he gives me
like a really big outline,
so that was his idea,
and I suspect though, when we
were kids, because James is
about ten years older than
me, but when we were kids,
there was a cartoon
show called the Jetsons,
and we were all promised robots
were going to be taking care
of everything and we'd be
flying hover cars and stuff.
So I think he just said
what if there was a house
that was filled with all those
robots that we were promised.
So that was his idea.
I don't know exactly
where he got that one,
but most stories start
with a big what if.
Yes, over here?
>> Have you ever
thought of teaming
up with different authors?
>> Chris Grabenstein: Have
I ever thought about teaming
up with different authors?
Well, I've known James
Patterson since 1984,
and I have now teamed
up with my wife,
and we've written
a book together,
and she's much more
attractive than James Patterson,
I will say that right now.
[laughter] Yes?
>> How much of James
Patterson's books do you write?
>> Chris Grabenstein: I
work on, the way he does it,
he comes up with the whole
story, which to me is more
than 50 percent of a book.
He'll give me like
an 80-page outline,
and then my job every month is
to send him like 10,000 words.
Then he gets on the phone,
and the best ones are
great, keep going.
The worse conversations are,
do you have a pen and a pad
of paper, because that means
he's got like lots of notes.
So then I'll make those
changes, and I'll go back
and forth like four times.
So I basically write the first
draft based on his outline,
and then he does the final
draft all by himself.
When the book I Funny came out,
there was two characters
named Zits and Useless,
and I went, who are they?
Oh, Jim made up those names.
So he is, the guy, I've
worked with him since 1984.
He is a workaholic in the
best sense of the word.
He's always up at
5:00 in the morning.
He writes every day.
The man is a maniac.
Yes?
>> Hi, in your opinion, what's
the best book you've written?
>> Chris Grabenstein: What's
the best book I've written.
Ooh, that's a tough one,
because I do love them all.
I think that's better
for you to decide.
Because some of them are
different, like the I Funnies
and the Wonderlands might
appeal to kids who--
well when I was a kid, they
called me a reluctant reader,
and I loved books
with illustrations
because you would read a
page or two and go, ooh,
a picture, I can take a break.
And then you'd read two more
pages and see a picture.
So I love those because
they reach some kids I
otherwise wouldn't.
The best book, I don't know.
Like my first one, The
Crossroads, I wrote for kids,
I just reread that recently.
It's pretty creepy, so I
like that one a lot too.
I like them all.
No bad books is my motto.
Thank you.
Yes, over here?
Oh, probably the last
question I think here, yes.
>> How do you work together
with James Patterson?
>> Chris Grabenstein: Very
well, don't you think?
No, we, he does the outline, and
I execute and send him pages,
and then he does the
final draft like that.
So we're not in the room.
I will do one more
question over here,
and then I'm going
to wrap it up.
>> How do you think of
the clues for the books?
>> Chris Grabenstein: Oh, yes.
Everyone thinks I'm a genius for
coming up with all those puzzles
and stuff, but you know what?
It's like a teacher,
when they write a test,
they know the answer
they're looking
for when they write
the question.
So all the puzzles are usually
designed to deliver a clue
or an answer that I
know, so then it's
up to me to work backwards.
Whenever you write a mystery
or a puzzle mystery,
work backwards.
Know what the ending is, what
you want, and then you can come
up with the most
complicated fun riddle
in the world to get that answer.
Well, thank you guys so
much for coming out today
and being the first to see
the new Lemoncello cover.
That's kind of exciting.
Thank you so much.
Oh, I know, someone-- who's
coming, and then I'm going
to be, at 1:00 I'm going to
be in line 14, I think, yes.